[موسيقى]
اذا الغيم تنهمر الحروف
فان لبست مقاليد المعاني مسطره تنوء بها
الرفوف
فتحنا في صميم العلم بابا فقال الدهر قد
جاز الوقوف
[موسيقى]
وجودك كله حسن
الابتداء السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]
يقول الله تعالى في سوره هود واخذ الذين
ظلموا الصيحه
فاصبحوا في ديارهم جاثمين كان لم يغنوا
فيها اي كانهم لم يقيموا في ديارهم ولم
يعيشوا فيها قط كان لم يغنوا فيها اي كلام
يعيش فيها لا علاقه للمفرده بالغنى وكثره
الاموال
في الفرق بين الشق والشق والشقه والشقاء
يقول الله تعالى تكاد السماوات يتفطرن منه
وتنشق الارض تنشق بمعنى تتصدع وقال تعالى
وتحمل اثقالكم الى بلد لم تكونوا بالغه
الا بشق الانفس الشقه بمعنى التعب
والصعوبه وفي قوله تعالى لو كان عرضا
قريبا وسفرا قاصدا للتبعوك ولكن بعدت
عليهم الشقه الشقه معناها الطريق والمسير
واما قوله تعالى وان تولوا فانماهم في
شقاق الشقاق جاءته نبي معنى الخلاف
والعداوه
[موسيقى]
همم
النافذه كلمه ذات اصل عربي الجذر النفاجاه
وهي تعني الريح شديده الهبوب يقال سحابه
نافجه كثيره المطر وهي ايضا وعاء المسك في
جسم الظبي وكانت العرب قبل الاسلام يقولون
اذا ولدت لاحدهم بنت هنيئا لكم نافجه اي
المعظمه لمالك لانه سيزوجها فياخذ مهرها
من الابل في يضمها الى ابنه فاين
يكسرها ويرفعها
[موسيقى]
سال رجل نحويا عن حال اهله فقال كيف اهلك
بكسر الله
فاجابهم نحوي مطلوبه ان شاء الله والصحيح
انه يقول كيف اهله يضم الله وهم العشيره
اما بالكسر فمن الهلاك اي الموت
النحويون مشكله مثل شعراء المحاوره لا
يوجد سبيل الى التخلص من شرها
[موسيقى]
يقول المثل تجوع الحره ولا تاكل بثدييها
فما قصه هذا المثل
اول من قال ذلك الحارس بن سليل الاسدي
وكان حديثا لعلقمه ابن خصبه الطائي زهره
فنظر الى ابنته الزباء وكانت من اجمل اهل
الدهرها فاعجب بها فقال له اتيتك خاطبا
وقد ينكح الخاطب ويدرك الطالب ويمنح
الراغب فقال له علقمه انت كف كريم يقبل
منك الصفو ويؤخذ منك العفو فاقم تنظر في
امريكا
الى امها فقال ان الحارث ابن سبيل سيد
قومي حسبا ومنصبا وبيتا وقد خطب الينا
الزباء فلا ينصرفن الا بحاجته فقالت
امراته لابنتها اي الرجال احب اليك الكهل
الجحجه الواصل المناح ام الفتى الوضاح
قالت لا بلي الفتى الوضاح
جلست تقنيعها وقالت يا ابنتي ان الفتى
يغيرك وان الشيخ يميرك وليس الكهل الفاضل
الكثير النائائل في الحديث السن الكثير
المن فلم تزل امها بها حتى غلبتها على
رايها
فتزوجها الحارث على 150 من الابل وخادم
والف درهم ورحل بها الى قومه فبينه هو
جالس ذات يوم وهي الى جانبه اذ اقبل اليه
شباب من بني اسد يتصارعون
ثم ارخت عينيها بالبكاء وقال لها ما يبكي
قالت مالي ولا الشيوخ الناهضين كالفروخ
فقال لها ذكرت في امك اجوع الحره ولا تاكل
بثدييها اما وابي الى رب غاره شهدتها
وسبيه
شفتها وخمره شربتها فالحقي باهلك فلا حاجه
لي فيك وضرب المثل للدلاله على ان المراه
الحره لا تقبل ان تضع انوثتها وسيله
للوصول الى المال والثروه او المنصب او اي
شيء من عرض الدنيا
[موسيقى]
يقول ابن زيدون في قصيدته الرائعه لا
تحسبون ايكم عنا يغيرنا ان طال ما غير
الراي المحبين والله ما طلبت قهوه هنا
بدلا منكم ولن صرفت عنكم
امانينا ولا استفدنا خليلا عنك يشغلنا ولا
اتخذنا بديلا
يا ساري البرق ذات القصر فسقي به من كان
صرف الهوى والود يسقينا ويا نسيم الصباح
بلغ تحيتنا من لو على البعد حيا كان
يحيينا
في هذه القصيده بيت اردده دائما يقول غير
العدا من تساقين الهوى تدعوا بان غصه فقال
الدهر امين
[موسيقى]
هي غضبانه ولا تقل كسلانه قل كسلا ولا
تقول حيرانه بل حيره ولا تقلنا نعسانه بل
نعسه فقد ذكر النحات ان كل ما جاء على وزن
فعلان والنته على وزن فعل
قل اعمل النجاح ولا تقل امل في النجاح
لانه فعلا يتعدى بنفسه
قل لا ابالي به ولا اباليه ولا تقل لا
ابالي له لان الفعل بال لا يتعدى بالله
[موسيقى]
يقولون للكلام الهزل طق حنك واتقوا صوت
الضرب على الجامد اما الحنك فهو فك الفم
الاسفل ويراد بطق الحنك ان الكلام لا
فائده منه الا سماعه هذا الطق وفي الخليج
يستعملون طقطقه عليه اي مزح معه وهذا من
التقاطيق والتقطقه وهو خفه الروح في
الكلام المضحك
تضعوا النساء المريول على صدور اطفالهم
والمريول الثوب يوضع على صدر الطفل ليقيا
ثوبه من روله اي لعابه
والمريول اسم مفعول من الفعل رال يبدو ان
اصله المريول عليه لكن حذف الجار والمجرور
لكثره الاستعمال واسم هذا اللعاب عند
العامه الريل وفصيحها الروال وبعضهم
يجاهلون للواو همزه يقولون الرئال
[موسيقى]
الفرق بين الحجه والحجه والحجه
الحجه بكسر الحاء هي السنه والجمع وحجاج
يقول تعالى على ان تاجرني ثماني حجج اما
الحجه بضم الحاء فهي الدليل والبرهان وتلك
حجتنا اتيناها ابراهيم على قومه اما الحجه
بفتح الحاء فهي اسم المره من الحج فيقال
حججت حجه واحده
[موسيقى]
مره اشعب بقوم ياكلون فقال ماذا تاكلون
قالوا سما يريدون التخلص من تطفله فقال
الحياه بعدكم لا قيمه لها وجلس ياكل معهم
هذا الشعب فيها مثلا عند اهل الشام يقولون
ماني مفارقك وحياه خالك هذا نفس الموضوع
[موسيقى]
كنت قد سالتكم في تويتر ماذا تعرفون من
مواقف الصعاليك واشعارهم وقد وصلت منكم
مشاركات جميله استعرضوا معكم بعضها فيما
يلي
هذه مشاركه من الشاعر سعد بن مرعي الهاجري
يقول الا هل اتى الحسناء ان حليلها تابط
شرا واكتنيت ابا وهبي
اسمه فاين له صبري على معظم الخطب واين له
باس كباس وسوره واين له في كل فاتحه قلبي
طبعا هذه الابيات فيها اشاره الى الرجل
الذي اراد ان
يباد يبادل الاسماء بينه وبينك بطل
يعني حتى لو اخذت اسمي لن تصبح بشجاعه ولم
يصبح لك همم امتلكه منباس والثوره
مشاركه من ايناس تقول كان انبلهم كما قيل
عروه عروه ابن الورد قال عنه الخليفه عبد
الملك بن مروان من زعم ان حاتما
اسمحوا الناس فقد ظلم عروه ابن الورد تقول
الا اقصر من الغزو
واشتكى لها القول طرفا احمر
مشاركه ايضا من عبد الهادي يقول من القصص
قصه تابط شرا مع ابي كبير الهذلي
اما الشعر فقوله عروه اذا المرء لم يبعث
بسواما ولم يرح عليه ولم تعطف عليه اقاربه
فلا الموت خير للفتى من حياته تقيرا ومن
مولى تدب عقاربه
مشاركه ايضا من مجبل عوض يقول لعمرو كما
بالارض ضيق على امرئ سرى راغب او راهبا
وهو يعقلك اختيار جميله صراحه اتيتم بها
من اشعار الصعاليك
محمد او مه انج يقول ما اروع لاميه العرب
للشنفر وعزائى لمن لم يقراها بعد
ابو الطيب يقول ملح الجاهليه وحاله متفرده
وقيام عاليه وتمرد على تسلط الاغنياء وظلم
المجتمعات
ومشاركه ايضا من اركان يقول وسائله اين
الرحيل وسائل ومن يسال الصعلوك اين مذاهبه
الله
ومشاركه اخيره من فيصل ابو طفيل يقول قول
عروه ماب الثراء يسود كل مسود
ولكن بالفعال يسود
جميل جدا اشكركم هذه المشاركات اللطيفه
وبهذا تصل معكم الى كتاب هذه الفقره
واذكركم بان تضعوا واسم تاملات الجزيره
دائما عندما تشاركون معنا في التقرير
على رفوف المكتبات العربيه تستلقي سير
عظيمه لرجال عظام اليوم احدثكم عن رجلين
عن تابط شرا
واحد من الشعراء الذين فقدوا استقرارهم في
مجتمع جاهلي تميز بغياب العداله
الاجتماعيه
من شعراء الصعاليك الذين افردوا من
القبيله سلطه هجومه على تركيبه القبيله
متمردا عليها كحال الصعاليك الذين عرفوا
بالعصر الجاهليه النظام القبلي حط من شانه
وانكره لانه كان من الغربه العرب فما كان
منه الا انت قاوم النظام الطبقي الذي كان
يرفع مكانه الانسان لنسبه وماله
هو الشاعر الصعلوك ثابت بن جابر الفهمي
الملقب
بتابط شرا من اهل تهامه والحجاز
نشات 14
مراره الفقر تزوجت امه من ابي كبير
الهودلي بعد موت ابيه
فحاول ابو كبير قتله باعازا من امه ولكنه
فشل اما سببه تسميته فيعود الى روايه
عديده منها انه قتل غولا ووضعه تحت ابطه
ومشى به الى قبيله ثقيله اضبط شرا ومن
الروايات ان امه طلبه ان ياتيها بشيء
فاحضر افاعيه بعد اصطيادها ووضعها في جراب
متابطا اياها
وقيله روايات ايضا منها انه كان كلما خرج
الى غزوه وضع سيفه تحت ابطه وله حكايات
كثيره تروي شجاعته
فاصبحت والغول الايجاره يا جاره الانتماء
فمن سال اين توجد جارتي فان لها باللواء
منزله وكنت اذا ما هدمت اعتزمت واحر اذا
قلت ان افعل
انتهينا الشعر الى جانب السفن والتصالح
عاش في القطار ومجاهد الارض يعانقه الفقر
والتشرد والتمرد مؤمنا بان الحق لا يؤخذ
الا بالقوه ولا سبيل الى المحافظه على
استمراره وفرض وجوده الا بالسلب وهو الذي
كسر قانون القبيله والمجتمع الجاهلي
بثورته ضد عرفها
انفصل عن دائره التقليد في القصيده ثورته
مع صعاليك عصره لم تقتصره على مجتمع
القبيله الذي لم ينصفهم بالتجاوز ذلك ليصل
الى القصيده التي كانت تنتهي جهجا لا يحيد
عنه الشعراء فجاءت قصائد الصهاريج في صراع
مع الواقع الجاهلي يشكل عوالم من التشرد
واثبات الذات والامل والياس والجوع
والكرامه كل هذا اجتمع بالقصيده لتحلق في
افقن واسع لتفجر ثوره من الشعر تمرد على
الحياه التي قست على تابط شرا واضرابه
فشكاها ببناء شهري كسر فيه المالوف مبتعدا
عن المنهج الطالب
يا عيد مالك من شوق وغيره
على الاهوال طراقي يسري على العين والحيات
محتفيا نفسي فداؤك من سار على ساقي
اشتهرت بسرعه
وديعين وكان يفاخر ويبالغ في وصفه سرعته
يقول لا شيء اسرع
اذا جناح بجنبريد خفاقي حتى نجوت ولما
ينزع سلابي بوهاله من قبل
وحياه التشرد التي الفها عم قتل لديها
الاحساس بالكرامه التي كانت متاصله في
قياده ولعل كرامه الصعاليك هي التي دفعتهم
الى الخروج على نظام القبيله ورفضهم
للاضطهاد والنكران لوجودهم فبرزت في
قصائدهم نفحه اثبات الذات فالغصه الدائمه
في اعماقهم كانت لا تهدا اثارهم
ولا اقول اذا ما خلت نصرمت
نفسيه من شوق واسفقي اني اذا خله ظنت
بنائلها وامسكت بضاعف الوصل احزاقي نجوت
منها نجايا من مجيله اذ القيت ليله دخلت
الرهط اروقي
المجتمع الجاهلي فكان واقعيا سلط الضوء
على حياه الصعلوك غير المستقره حياه
الساعي الى مواجهه عالميه بالحماسه فوضت
تجاربه الحياتيه وتحدياته للطبيعه
وتناقضات صور واقعه في شعره لعله يتالف مع
مجتمع الجاهليه
على ارض واقعيه ترك اثره واضحا في بناء
قصيده
فناصر في ابياته على الحياه القاسيه التي
عاشها والاماكن التي كان يقتل فيها
وقله كسنان الرمح بارزه
احيانا في شهور الصيف محراقي
بادرت قمتها صاحبي وما كسروا حتى رميت
اليها بعد اشراقه
الذي اعتمد نهج الفتك والنهب ليضمن
استمراريه حياته ما حشره بمشاعر عميقه خلق
جو يتناقض مع شخصيته يذكر في قصيدته
المفضليه صفات الصاحب الحقيقي الذي يبتغيه
والذي يجمع الحكمه والرئاسه والخبره
بشخصيه واحده
لكنما عولي ان كنت ذاعلا على بصير بكسب
الحمد سباقي حمى للالويه شهاده انديه
قوالي محكمه جواب اثاقي
وله شعر يعاتب فيه من يدومه على اسلوب
حياته
ان بعض اللون
ابقيته باقي اني زعيم لان لم تتركوا عذلي
ان يسال الحي عني اهل اثار
لقد غلب على شعره استخدام المفردات الغريب
الخشنه العائد الى قساوه الحياه التي
عاشها القارئ يحتاج الى معاجم لمعرفه
كانما حصا قوادمه او ام خشن بدي شفته
وطباقي لهذا البيت يتحدث عن جري السريع
ولم تغب الحكمه عن ابياته فراه يدعو الى
الاجتهاد والاحتيال للخلاصي من اي مكروه
الى المرء لم يحتل وقد جلد جده اضاع وقاسي
امره وهو مدبر ولكن اخو الحزن الذي ليس
نازلا به الخطب الا وهو للقصد مبصر
توفيق تقبط شرا قبل اكثر من 1000 و 400
سنه لكنه لم يغادر عالمه الا بعد ان ارخله
بواقعيه صادقه
[موسيقى]
هجرتك طائعا رزق الشباب
فقد تقول اليراع على الكتاب
حسابي في الهواء رقم وشعر ودمع ليس يدخل
في الحساب
السلام ورحمه الله
[موسيقى]